[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUKE GAMBLE: I think the
reason I'll always play tennis
is because tennis has
really been an instrumental
part of making me who I am.
And this is where Princeton
has been really special for me,
just the number of people that
I've gotten to do and share
this journey with -
my coaches, my teammates,
and also just the huge athletic
sort of body and tennis
has been that for me.
It's totally shaped my
person, in a way which I'm
at least really thankful for.
Being an athlete,
in general, has
been absolutely central
to my time at Princeton.
And I think it's extended my
academic environment, as well,
because you get all this
extra time in a really
sort of intimate environment
with other student-athletes who
are also really
smart people, and who
also care about their studies.
And so it's actually
complemented
my academic life in a really
cool way, not to mention
the sort of just sort of
communal element of what
it means to be a
Princeton athlete.
There's a really good sort of
society and community, I think,
that we all have
because we're going
through the same sort of stuff.
BILLY PATE: Luke has probably
grown as much as anybody here,
and I think he's really
benefited from the Princeton
experience.
He is a very, very
articulate guy.
He's a voracious reader.
He came here with
the idea he was going
to do English, and read a lot.
I remember, his
recruiting visit,
he was worried he wouldn't
be able to read the things he
wanted to read on the outside,
because the professors
would have him reading so much.
But I think he's really done a
good job of utilizing Princeton
and getting all the resources
out of Princeton for him
and using it for,
you know, gain later,
so it's improving his
life, and of course,
improving it on the team as well.
LUKE GAMBLE: One of
our favorite things
to do as a team is
on Friday mornings,
it's called Reading
with the Tigers.
And we partner with
a local school,
and it's organized by the
Student Athlete Service
Council.
And we go and we read with
young kids, elementary students,
and it's a great way for
us to sort of bond together
outside the regular academic
or athletic environment
but still do something
that we think is
worthwhile with the community.
BILLY PATE: I would say
each head coach here treats
their players like a family.
So you want to see
them excel, and you
want to see them come back
for reunions, for alumni
gatherings you have,
to come to matches
or where they're on the road.
They'll be all scattered,
probably, across the country,
and they'll come out
to there to see us.
And hopefully, they'll take
some life lessons here,
whether it's from the
University or from our program
or just learning
from each other,
because there's a lot to learn
from each guy on the team.